so here i'm going to talk about the
laplacian
and the laplacian is a certain operator
in the same way that the divergence or
the gradient or the curl or even just
the derivative are operators the things
that take in some kind of function and
give you another function so in this
case let's say we have a multivariable
function
like f that just takes in a two
dimensional input f of x y
so you might imagine it's graph as being
something like this
where you know the input space is this x
y plane here so each of the points x y
is a point here and then the output is
just given by the height of that graph
so the laplacian of f is denoted with a
right side up triangle and it's going to
give you a new scalar valued function
of x and y so it's going to give you a
new function that takes in a
two-dimensional input and just outputs a
number and it's kind of like a second
derivative because the way that it's
defined is that you take the divergence
of the gradient
of the gradient of your function f
so that's kind of how it's defined the
divergence of the gradient of f and more
common notation that you might see here
is to take that upside down triangle
nabla dot product
with nabla
of f
so remember if f is a scalar valued
function then the gradient of f gives
you a vector field a certain vector
field but the divergence of a vector
field gives you another scalar valued
function so this is the sense in which
it's a second derivative but let's see
if we can kind of understand intuitively
what what this should mean because the
gradient if you'll remember gives you
the slope of steepest ascent so it's a
vector field in the input space of x and
each one of the vectors points in the
direction that you should walk such that
if this graph is kind of like a hill on
top of you it tells you the direction
you should go to increase your direction
the most rapidly
and if that seems unfamiliar or doesn't
make sense maybe go take a look at that
video on gradients and graphs and how
they relate to each other
so with the specific graph that i have
pictured here when you have kind of the
top of a hill all of the points around
it the direction that you should walk is
towards the top of that hill whereas
when you have kind of like the bottom a
little a little gully here all of the
directions you should walk to increase
the value of the function most rapidly
are directly away from that that valley
which you might call a local minimum
so let's let's temporarily get rid of
the graph just so we can look at the
gradient field here pretty clearly and
now let's think about what the
divergence is supposed to represent
so now the divergence and again if if
this feels unfamiliar maybe go back and
take a look at the divergence videos but
the divergence has you imagining that
this vector field corresponds to some
kind of fluid flow so you imagine little
like water molecules and at any given
moment they're moving along the vector
that they're attached to
so for example if you had a water
molecule that started off kind of here
it would start by going along that
vector and then kind of follow the ones
near it and it looks like it kind of
ends up
ends up in this spot and a lot of the
water molecules seem to kind of converge
over there whereas over here the water
molecules tend to go away when they're
following those vectors away from this
point and when they go away like that
when you have a whole bunch of vectors
kind of pointed away that's an
indication that divergence is positive
because they're diverging away so over
here divergence is positive whereas the
opposite case where all of the water
molecules are kind of coming in towards
a point that's where divergence is
negative and in another area let's say
it was kind of like this center point
where you know you have some water
molecules that looks like they're coming
in but other ones are going out and at
least from this picture it doesn't seem
like you know the ones going out are
doing so at a faster rate or slower than
they are here this would be roughly zero
divergence
so now let's think about what it might
mean when you take the divergence of the
gradient field of f so let me kind of
clear up the markings i made on top of
it here
points of high divergence points where
it diverges a lot here why are those
vectors pointing away and if we pull up
the graph again
the reason they're pointing away is
because the direction of steepest
descent is kind of uphill everywhere you
are in a valley whereas in the opposite
circumstance where
divergence is highly negative because
points are converging towards it why are
they pointing towards it well this is a
gradient field so they're pointing
towards that spot because that's where
any anywhere around it you should walk
towards that spot to go uphill
so in other words the divergence of the
gradient is very high at points that are
kind of like minima at points where
everyone around them tends to be higher
but the divergence of the gradient is
low at points to look more like maximum
points where when you evaluate the
function at all of the points around
that input point they give something
smaller so this laplacian operator is
kind of like a measure of
how much of a minimum point is this x y
it will be very positive when f
evaluated at that point tends to give a
smaller value than f evaluated at
neighbors of that point but it'll be
very negative if when you evaluate f at
that point it tends to be bigger than
its neighbors and this should feel kind
of analogous to the the second
derivative in in ordinary calculus when
you have some kind of graph of just a
single variable function the second
derivative you know the second
derivative of x will be low it'll be
negative at points where it kind of
looks like a local maximum but over here
the second derivative of x would be
would be positive at points that kind of
look like a local minimum so in that way
the laplacian is sort of a an analog of
the second derivative for scalar valued
multivariable functions and in the next
video i'll go through an example of that